sur ce plateau gérald kersee qui vient
de nous rejoindre un médecin urgentiste
à l'hôtel-dieu bonjour merci d'être avec
nous une annonce donc ce matin un
d'olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé les écoles fermer 15 jours minimum
il souhaite que la durée sur la plus
courte possible mais quinze jours
minimum comment est-ce que vous
accueillez cette information de ce matin
bon à partir du moment où les écoles
sont fermées il faut qu'elles sont faits
réels soit fermée pour un certain nombre
de jours et qu'un jour ça correspond à
plus ou moins la durée d'incubation donc
l'idée c'est de faire vraiment un shot
down sur le virus qui pourraient
circuler dans les écoles donc cette
correspond à plus de quatorze jours deux
jours ça ne servait à rien et après ça
paraît pas raisonnable il faut qu'on
voit les choses évoluer notamment à la
situation italienne à 11 ans n'est calé
sur la situation italienne avec huit
jours de décalage en disant si on est
dans la situation en italie ça sera dans
huit jours donc voilà pourquoi il dans
le vieil jours
65 millions de personnes chez elles
exactement ça sera dans huit dix jours
on sera fixé- donc l'idée c'est de ne
pas arriver à la situation italienne
c'est à dire un afflux de patients dans
les hôpitaux et donc pour cela il faut
cantonné c'est ce qu'on appelle les
mesures de distanciation social on met
les gens les zones loin des autres et en
particulier les enfants qui sont
porteurs probablement même réservoir de
ce virus et qui peuvent le contaminer à
d'autres camarades de classe et ensuite
l'exporter et le transmettent aux grands
parents à la maison etc
alors justement mettez le point sur
quelque chose d'intéressant il y aura un
service de garde région par région
d'après emmanuel macron veut dire quoi
on délocalise et des crèches et
finalement la contamination va avoir
lieu ailleurs les leurs sont délocalisés
alliant la mesure elle est nécessaire
clairement pour essayer de stopper le
virus est une mesure nécessaire
d'arrêter les écoles les crèches parce
que c'est un lieu de circulation
notamment entre entre les plus jeunes
est-ce qu'elle sera suffisante on n'en
sait rien c'est à dire que c'est une des
premières mesures avant le confinement
évidemment donc on le saura avec la
semaine prochaine je vais d'ici si les
choses se passent bien ou si on a cette
vague de malades après elle est
difficile à mettre en place
y compris d'ailleurs pour des gens qui
ont des métiers soignants qui sont en
première ligne et qui ne peuvent pas
forcément organisé d'ailleurs au passage
à l'assistance publique hôpitaux de
paris maintient ses crèches ouvertes
donc on voit bien qu'elle est un peu à
géométrie variable
cette cette mesure de fermeture des
crèches ou des lieux ou des lieux de
garde
quant à la déclinaison régionale je sais
pas ce qu'a voulu dire chef de l'état
est ce que c'est aux régions d'organiser
des modes de garde mais si on ferme les
écoles pour faire d'autres modes de
garde qui met des gens ensemble ça n'a
pas de sens l'objectif c'est de mettre
des mesures de barrières entre les gens
et donc que les individus ne soit pas
ensemble c'est ça la distanciation
sociale donc si c'est pour transposer
une classe dans un dans une salle de
cours ou de je ne sais quoi du conseil
régional ça n'a aucun sens bien sûr
l'idéal c'est le confinement à la maison
que les gamins les enfants les adultes
et des jeunes adultes ou les ados reste
à la maison
on voit bien que c'est compliqué et ça
veut dire ne pas les emmener non plus
chez le voisin ne pas les emmener chez
les grands parents surtout pas parce que
les grands parents sont plus à risque 1
puisqu'ils sont par définition plus âgés
donc on avait que la mise en heure et
elle est compliquée en ce moment pour
parler de distanciation sociale les
écoles les crèches fermées
mais d'un autre côté les élections
municipales sont maintenus et d'un autre
côté également les transports en commun
sont eux maintenu la la distanciation
social n'est pas forcément parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de monde dans le métro
surtout aux heures de pointe ou sur le
métro parisien lyonnais marseillais on
voit bien qu'on est dans une balance la
décision politique c'est une balance
entre quels sont les impératifs
sanitaires et est-ce qu'il faut vraiment
paralysé c'est l'autre côté de la
balance de l'autre plateau paralyser
complètement le pays et donc l'économie
et donc c'est cet équilibre là qui fait
la décision politique c'est une décision
c'est une première étape
la fermeture des écoles qui a pas un
coût économique majeure et qui permet de
garder en réserve d'autres mesures si
jamais la situation venait à s'aggraver
donc il y avait dans le bien qu'on le
garde sous le coude mais il ya un
paradoxe on en garde sous le sous le
pied alors après on voit bien que fermé
des écoles ça coûte pas grand chose les
parents ça va les embêter pour le mode
de garde etc
mais économiquement c'est encore
supportable est acceptable ça aurait été
beaucoup plus compliqué avec des
transports par exemple là où il ya un
peu une ambiguïté voir une contradiction
c'est que quand on dit que les élections
municipales et l'autre code donc les
personnes y compris les personnes âgées
vont se déplacer et qu'on dit aux
personnes de plus de 70 ans de ne pas se
déplacer donc on voit bien que là il ya
une contradiction les élections
municipales c'est clair que c'est un
brassage de populations quand vous avez
40 millions d'électeurs mais mec de
l'abstention ça fera une bonne vingtaine
de millions qui vont se rendre aux urnes
c'est un brassage de population c'est
donc de la circulation potentiel de
virus on en profite pour rappeler les
gestes barrière que ça soit dans le
bureau de vote avant ou après ou au
travail ou ailleurs c'est le lavage des
mains ça c'est fondamental
ça paraît anodin mais c'est vraiment ça
qui peu avant où est la place des
mesures de confinement casser la
propagation du virus lavage des mains en
priorité pour tous les fronts respecte
est également à mettre de sécurité
lorsqu on se parle ou encore tousser
dans le coude
toujours pour revenir sur votre terme de
distanciation
c'est magnifique de des épidémiologistes
et des infectiologues justement c'est de
mettre de la distance entre les
individus et après il ya plein de panel
de mesures mais la distance entre les
individus
quid de la distance entre les états en a
vu les différentes réactions politiques
suite à l'allocution hier de d'emmanuel
macron marine le pen elle se plaint
qu'il n'y a pas de contrôles
supplémentaires aux frontières alors que
l'allemagne par exemple le met en place
elle ferme elle ne ferme pas sa
frontière avec avec la france mais il ya
des contrôles aux frontières est ce que
la france devrait faire ça comment
est-ce que vous accueillez 7
on voit bien et ça commence et que
donald trump qui a arrêté tous les vols
qui est tous les vols venant d'europe
qu'elle qui ont même l'europe de la
nouvelle chine en termes virologique en
termes de virus du coronavirus on voit
bien que c'est plus un discours
politique avec l'argumentation sanitaire
parce que sur le plan sanitaire j'aille
vers le mal est fait c'est trop tard
pour fermer les frontières comme aux
états unis le virus il est déjà sur le
territoire en allemagne en france il y
eut aussi d'en fermer les frontières n'a
plus de sens ça aurait peut-être eu un
sens c'est ça hein de ça deux sens au
tout début d'une épidémie ce taire quand
vous avez un seul foyer et que vous
voulez à tout prix éviter qui est un cas
qui rentre sur votre territoire là en
bloc la frontière à condition de pouvoir
l'a bloqué fixe et efficacement et de
manière hermétique
la ce a un sens mais quand vous avez une
diffusion virale qui est de partout et
un autre sens médecins et scientifiques
le virus il est partout il est partout
sur le territoire il n'est pas
uniquement d'ailleurs avec les 2200 et
quelques cas à faire que le virus
il a circulé les gens se sont immunisés
l'immense majorité des gens n'ont pas vu
qu'ils avaient un virus et ce virus qui
est sur le territoire où vous voyez bien
que ça n'a aucun sens de fermer les
frontières même les contrôles de
température à la frontière
franco-allemande vous ne pouvez très
bien ne pas avoir de température et
avoir le coronavirus dans vos poumons
donc on voit bien que ces espèces de
filet mais les mailles sont extrêmement
large
c'est plus pour rassurer politiquement
et la communication politique qu une
efficacité et une mesure sanitaire
dernière question rapidement il nous
reste plus beaucoup de temps gerald
kerzec ce qu'il ya un risque de
saturation des services de réanimation
leur risque il ya deux points faibles à
l'hôpital oh ce sont les samu donc il
faut arrêter de les appeler maintenant
pour simplement de la fièvre ou une
petite tout ça c'est le médecin traitant
qui doit gérer c'est uniquement les cas
graves on appelle le samu et le deuxième
point critique des tout à fait raison ce
sont les réanimations on a 12 millions
en france comme en italie c'est à peu
près le même tissu hospitalier si jamais
on a énormément de patients qui viennent
et qu'il faut réanimer est un tube dans
la bouche les ventiler m de l'oxygène
c'est là le point critique parce qu'on
va pouvoir prendre moins de douze mille
malades
jeudi - parce qu'il a tous les infarctus
et les autres patients qui ont besoin de
réanimation en temps normal si on a plus
de douze mille malades ça va poser
problème c'est le monde a faim merci
gerald karzaï d'avoir répondu à ma
question je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin urgentiste à l'hôtel dieu